well guys if you've been watching my
reviews for a while you know that M
night Shyamalan is a director that
really inspired me as a teenager his
first few films really got me into the
idea of filmmaking the past few films he
has made have taken a different path
though thus after earth was something I
was very curious about after earth is
directed by M night Shyamalan and it
stars Jaden Smith and Will Smith why do
I say Jaden first because he is the star
of this movie and Will Smith is like
this extremely decorated warrior of his
time he's the only guy to ever be able
to ghost and essentially someone who has
been in a war somewhere who lost all of
his fear it just went away and suddenly
became invisible to all the people
around him and he was able to fight and
he ghosted so his son looks up to him a
lot as a young ranger in training and
when they go out on a mission together
and get marooned on earth earth is now
this desolate place filled with violent
creatures who want to kill you at their
first sight of you and since Will Smith
is injured Jaden Smith has to go out and
try to find this beacon to be able to
establish contact with their colony all
across the other edge of the universe
honestly I'm always interested to see
what M night Shyamalan gonna do because
even his failures are still interesting
because look here's the deal I was so
inspired by his first few movies they
really really got me into the idea of
filmmaking so much and I was so
interested in everything that guy did
after that the guy's a nice guy he
actually replied to me on Twitter once
he retweeted something that I wrote him
about signs which was really awesome for
me I was optimistic about after earth
because of Will Smith's involvement but
also because M night Shyamalan does not
share a full writing credit he shares
half the credit of the writing of this
movie which is a first for him in
regards to his big movies since The
Sixth Sense so I was thinking maybe he
was finally going to admit kind of that
he is a better director than he is a
writer the good news is after Earth is
not the disaster that the last airbender
was of course I could probably go in the
bathroom and take a crap right now and
make something better than The Last
Airbender if you are the director who
just made the last airbender there
really is nowhere else you can Co put up
if you go down even more after that
there's no hope for you after earth is
not an awful movie in my opinion but I
wouldn't really say it's a good movie
either I think it's a pretty
middle-of-the-road mediocre film but
thank goodness at least that it's not
like you're sitting there just in pain
like I wasn't in pain as I watched this
movie it was just a lot of it could have
been so much better and I'll explain to
you my reasons see I really like Will
Smith a lot like I've grown up watching
all of his movies he's such a likeable
actor and although he is good in this
movie I don't know if he was the right
casting for this role see there are
sometimes characters in movies that are
very silent very hardened just very
stoic like all the badass Clint Eastwood
characters from his westerns like that's
kind of like where Will Smith is like
except without the likability which is
amazing because it's Will Smith and it's
like so hard not to like that guy and
it's not that I didn't like him in this
movie it's just his character was so
dull I think the main problem here with
this casting was actually Jaden Smith
see this point it's like will Will Smith
ever play a father in a movie unless his
son is played by Jaden Smith as well is
Jaden Smith good in this movie sometimes
he is yes but sometimes he is just not
up to the challenge of this movie puts
in front of him I just didn't feel like
he was the right casting for this
character I think we needed a more
experienced young actor now before I get
into the directing let's talk about the
writing now as I said Shyamalan shares a
screen credit with the other writer and
you can kind of tell because this movie
has that thing that Shyamalan movies
have had as of late where characters say
really normal everyday lines but in this
extremely overly serious way I'm going
to go to the bathroom and I'm gonna wash
my hands and you're gonna sit over there
and you're gonna wait for me to come out
because I really had to take a crap I
don't know what happened along the way
but just something happened I think
maybe he went a little nuts after people
didn't like the ending of the village he
was like I know everyone will love this
movie it's gonna be amazing and then
people didn't like it he was like ah and
then just started making like mediocre
movies from then on but you can see like
a lot of his writing into this movie and
I wouldn't even be surprised if he wrote
way more than half of it alright let's
talk about the directing and the overall
look of this movie I have to say the
first like 15 minutes of this movie
looked so cheap I was just like please
tell me that the effects are gonna get
better than this please don't let this
be like that oh it's going to be a
disaster I know it's going to be a
disaster but once they got into space
and onto earth the effects did improve
slightly but I will say that overall the
effects in this movie are
supporting with those first few scenes
in space some of the green screen and
some of the sets looked so Star Trek
next generation which was a great TV
show that I loved as a kid but it's also
a TV show from the 90s you don't want
your sets to look like that when you're
making a movie in the year 2013 as the
movie progressed those throughout the
scenes on earth I could see like hints
of shamble ons greatness in there in his
direction some of the shots on earth
were fantastic some of the way he
constructed certain scenes were
fantastic there were some great scenes
in this movie it wasn't a complete
disaster and you could actually see like
okay maybe maybe somes
coming back in there maybe but it just
didn't mesh because the movie as a whole
is very dull I think if more attention
was given to character and less to the
situation I think would have been easier
to latch on to these people but overall
after earth is kind of a mediocre movie
the reason I appear slightly hopeful is
because it wasn't in my opinion a
complete disaster so it's like actually
I'm actually kind of happy about that
I'm gonna give after Earth a see I just
really think as a director that he
should make movies that are smaller than
this I don't know if he is the type of
director for these big movies I think
that his style wants to be these smaller
films like unbreakable or the sixth
sense or even signs which had special
effects but really was a small budget
movie compared to the rest of the movie
season making so guys if you have seen
after Earth let me know what you thought
of it below please and as always thank
you very much for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
Oh